je suis très content de vous faire cette
vidéo aujourd'hui ça fait un petit
moment que on parle de tout ça est quoi
une péloche france organise pour vous
faire gagner un super cadeau pas un
super cadeau pas deux supers cadeaux
mais trois supers cadeaux cd l'eau ce
qui va être à gagner aujourd'hui c'est
un tout qui est vraiment super
intéressant parce que c'est une
nouveauté si one place qui a sorti il ya
pa très très très longtemps
d'ailleurs si vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs
dit que le mois dès maintenant dans
commentaire est ce que vous l'avez vu
cette promo oui où non sur leur site je
vous explique
ils se sont rapprochés de google wyplosz
google google one place vous connaissez
et ils sont dit on va faire un truc est
super intéressant parce que pour toutes
les personnes qui décident d'acheter
owen +9 pour une pêche neuf pros ou une
puce huit pros juan +8 et est un web
plus noord et bien vous avez ça do faire
avec et ça c'est tout simplement un kit
stadia première et ça c'est super cool
donc ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui je
vous situer un peu vous expliquer ce qui
se passe et surtout je voulais faire
gagner je vous faire gagner un kit avec
d'un côté un one + 9 alors là j'ai pris
un web plus neuf pros vont vous les
patrimoines de plus de 20 points de plus
neuf pros vous allez gagner un mois de
plus neuf plus un kit stadia premières
ce qui vous permettra de venir jouer
avec votre one + 9 partout grâce au
cloud gaming de google et ça c'est
génial
[Musique]
on se parle bien ici du moins de plus
neuf et pas du wan +9 propre là j'ai
pris le pro j'aurais dû prendre le 9 mai
j'ai pris le pro ici je suis pas à paris
il est à paris donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai le projet pas loin de +9
mais on se parle bien du moins de plus
de comment ça va se passer
alors je vous situez extrêmement
rapidement vous avez un one + 9 one + 9
est ce que vous connaissez
quoi de plus noble c'est un super
smartphone d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas
vu je vous mets le lien quelque part en
ficher dans la description aller voir ce
smartphone pas ce qui est super bien
vous avez déjà un superbe écran amoled
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz et ça pour le gaming c'est
vraiment top
vous avez le meilleur processeur du
moment le sa dragonne 888 vous aller
jusqu'à 12 ou érable vous allez jusqu'à
256 giga de stockage tous à faire tomber
tout ça avec les meilleures technologies
du moment
vous avez de la recharge ces deux-là 25
65 t c'est la recharge la plus rapide du
moment que vous allez avoir chez one
love c'est l'arche à 65 watts
ça c'est aussi super bien ce qui fait
que vous avez un smartphone qui va hyper
vite vous avez un smartphone qui est
très bon d'autonomie sans smartphone
qu'elle l'a 5 je sais mieux on y injecte
du cloud gaming
ce qui fait qu'avec stadia ewan pleuvent
fois bien joué en mobilité de partout et
ça c'est super cool et en plus de ça
vous avez une superbe expérience
logiciel avec oxygène os mais ça je vous
ai déjà tout dit dans ma vidéo de tests
d'urines +9 2 vous invite à venir la
visionner pour découvrir ce smartphone
si ce n'est pas déjà le cas d'ailleurs
dit clairement aux commentaires est ce
que vous le connaissez déjà ce
smartphone ou alors absolument pas c'est
un smartphone qui est orienté gaming
grâce à la performance tout ce que vous
avez dans ses smartphones qui oriente et
visionnage de film de sherry social
smartphones qui orientaient photos grâce
à un partenariat avec castle blade est
une fois de plus tout est dans ma vidéo
de test et vous pouvez trouver à partir
de 719 euros
rassurez-vous nous on voulait ça c'est
cool rester connecté on va te regarder
ensuite et vous avez d'autres côté
google avec stadiers alors saga c'est
quoi c'est un service de cloud gaming
pour vouloir faire très rapidement le
cloud gaming c'est du jeu vidéo sur
internet jeux vidéo dans le club vous
voulez vous connecter vous jouez grâce
notamment avec votre petite planète
stadium ça c'est pendant une des
meilleures expériences à c'est très très
cool
vous avez votre tout péter vous avez
votre manette vous pouvez jouer
directement sur votre télé sur un
ordinateur
sur une tablette sur smartphones et
notamment sur une plus ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle
autant vous commencez votre parti sur
votre télé vous partez en mobilité vous
de battage à une heure de bus je me
connecte je prends ma manette je prends
mon smartphone je joue directement dans
mon bus parce que j'ai envie de
continuer vous jouer partout tout le
temps facilement dès lors vous avez une
connexion internet et ça c'est très très
cool avec sadia vous avez d'abonnement
qui coûte 9 euros 99 par mois ces stades
ya procès permet d'avoir accès à un
catalogue de jeux avec plein de jeux
gratuits compris dans l'abonnement à
savoir que si le premier mois gratuit
donc ça c'est très cool vous avez plein
de jeux ça c'est tout les jeux gratuits
vous en avez énormément vous avez hitman
vous en avez plein voilà de la moto vous
avez plein de jeux et tous les moyens
nouveaux jeux qui arrivent que vous
conservez bien évidemment gratuitement
avec votre abonnement à 9 euros 99 et si
vous voulez venir acheter d'autres jeux
vous pouvez vous n'êtes pas d'autres
jeux et assassin's creed
vous allez avoir un cyber punk 2077 vous
avez les dum
vous avez far cry 5 vous avez farming
simulator 19
vous allez fifa 2021 il y en a plein de
tous les côtés hitman 2 hitman 3 just
dance ya du lara croft vous avez
avengers monopoly également fin il ya
plein de jeux de tous les côtés donc ça
c'est vachement bien du pac man il ya
des jeux pour tout le monde
quelles que soient vos goûts vous
trouverez franchement de quoi venir vous
amuser ici donc c'est super cool et des
jeux il y en a de plus en plus il sait y
aura trois gagnants y en aura trois et
pas plus ça c'est déjà bien trois
gagnants c'est très cool mais si vous
avez prévu de changer vos smartphones et
que le wild +9 vous fait de l'oeil one +
9 août + 9 prg aurait pu susciter ou est
plus huit pros one + nord et bien vous
allez sur le site de one pluzz regardez
vous venez ici vous choisissez le
smartphone vous choisissez la couleur la
capacité bien évidemment et vous avez en
cadeau si votre kit stade ias qui coûte
00 euros
c'est très cool dans la limite des
stocks disponibles donc si ça vous
intéresse le lien et en maths dans la
description et ça on vous l'offre alors
pour participer c'est extrêmement simple
je vous explique le principe vous avez
un lien qui se situe juste en bas juste
en bas vous avez un lien vous cliquez
sur le lien vous avez petite question
comme ça au passage et à la suite de sa
toutes les bonnes réponses seront tirés
au sort convient sortir trois gagnants
trois gagnants qui gagneront leur one +
9 et leur kit stadia première pour venir
jouer en claude gaming partout tout se
situe dans cette boîte dans votre kit
sadia première édition vous avez
plusieurs choses
à une manette alors la manette si vous
n'êtes pas gamer ou si vous la
connaissez pas elle est super super cool
vous avez des boutons de tout côté
manceau une manette très clairement
c'est une super maniable qui est dédié
ici pour venir jouer à tous vos jeux
stadia vous avez également compris à
l'intérieur et supra coup c'est ça c'est
un chrome casque ultra alors ça vous
permettra de venir castet sur votre
téléviseur tout ce que vous voulez mais
également tous vos jeux très très
facilement vous la branchez et grâce à
google sadia vous allez pouvoir venir
jouer très facilement à tous vos jeux
sur votre télévision c'est vraiment cool
alors prévenir castet pas d'autre chose
un défi mais c'est tout ce qui me fera
plaisir
depuis notamment votre smartphone de one
plus ça c'est très très cool vous venez
le connecter directement ici en hdmi à
votre téléviseur vous avez une prise
avec du micro usb hop là qui est là j'ai
mélangé tous les câbles ici ils vont
venir charger et ce qui est super cool
c'est si vous voulez vraiment profiter
de la meilleure connexion vous venez le
connecter la directement avec une prise
rj45 c'est le profiterez de la meilleure
collection plutôt que de passer en wifi
et ce qui est très cool aussi c'est que
votre manette et bien prévenir la
recharge et hop là vous le branchez vous
la recharger il vous est reparti pour un
tour donc ça c'est très bien et lorsque
vous jouez avec votre smartphone de
roanne place eh bien vous prenez votre
smartphone vous prenez votre petit calme
s'il faut que dans le branché pour
l'instant avec un câble mais on pourra
le faire d'ici quelques temps en
bluetooth vous le prenez vous le
branchez vous ali mais en laissant
appuyer votre doigt ici allez on va se
faire un petit jeu pour la route il me
demandait ce que je veux jouer mais moi
je jouais sur cet écran la up
lecture je reprends mahlérien sauvegarde
j'étais pas très loin j'étais juste à
l'entraînement et la vrille et gk venir
jouer je me balade comme ça dans mon
environnement directement dans mon jeu
comme ça je peux bien jouer à tous les
jeux que je veux directement ici sur mon
smartphone c'est vraiment vraiment
génial et je vous dis une fois de plus
dès que j'en ai marre de jouer sur
smartphone ou alors que je suis de
retour chez moi
eh bien je continue sur ma télévision
grâce à mon crâne qu'à ce titre a donc
si vous voulez faire plaisir et si vous
voulez du club gaming avec votre one + 9
ici on est sur un prog mais on parle
bien du wall +9 avec votre petit stade
ias première pour venir jouer sur votre
smartphone
bien évidemment sur votre télé où vous
voulez venir casser tout ce que vous
voulez et bien c'est très simple il ya
trois lots mis en jeu vous venez cliquez
sur le lien en bas dans la description
les gagnants seront annoncés d'ici
quelques temps sur les réseaux sociaux
et si vous n'avez pas gagné et bien
c'est pas grave parce que si vous avez
prévu de changer votre smartphone vous
allez sur le site de one love et vous
avez dans la limite des stocks
disponibles et sur une durée limitée et
bien votre kit stadia première édition
en blanc comme ça qui va vous être
offerts avec l'achat de vos smartphones
et ça c'est une super nouvelle
à vous de jouer le lien est en bas bonne
chance merci à wembley ce qui m'offre
une opportunité de vous faire gagner ce
très joli cadeau ce jour dans beaucoup
d'amour prenez soin de vous participez
vous sentez l'agent de gueule ça c'est
la bonne nouvelle
à bientôt ciao